new developments arise in the connection
between the Trump whistleblower and
House Intelligence Committee Chairman
Adam Schiff the State Department
inspector general opens up another mess
and president from goes off in front of
the head of Finland I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
I mean I do have to say you have to feel
a little bit bad for the foreign leaders
who sit there while president from goes
because man when President Trump does
these press conferences and goes off on
the press and then goes off on the
Democrats and you are like the president
of Finland or the prime minister of
Finland and you are sitting there
looking like you just cannot wait to get
out and click Jim from the office it's
pretty it's pretty spectacular stuff
well a lot breaking in the news first I
think that it's important to make a note
that Andrew McCarthy makes today over at
the hill he of course is a legal
correspondent for National Review and he
gives some important information about
the background of this whole impeachment
inquiry and that is that so far it is
basically Kabuki theater meaning it's
not an official impeachment inquiry for
all the talk abouts an impeachment
inquiry and we're supposed to put all of
our focus into impeachment nothing has
actually fundamentally changed here's
what Andy McCarthy writes today he says
there is no impeachment inquiry there
are no subpoenas you're not to be
faulted if you think a formal inquest is
underway and that legal process has been
issued the misimpression is completely
understandable if you've been taking in
media coverage in particular reporting
on a haughty September 27th letter from
House Democrats presuming to direct
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo on pain
of citation for obstruction to cooperate
in their demands to depose State
Department officials and review various
records the letter is signed by not one
but three committee chairmen remember
your elementary math though zero is
still zero even when multiplied by three
what is portrayed as an impeachment
inquiry is actually just a made for
cable TV political soap opera the House
of Representatives is not conducting a
formal impeachment inquiry to the
contrary says Andy McCarthy
congressional Democrats are conducting
the 2020 political campaign the house
has not voted as a body to authorize an
impeachment inquiry what we have here
are partisan theatrics proceeding under
the abscissa Dixit of Speaker Nancy
Pelosi it raises the profile but not the
legitimacy of the same impeachment
inquiry and there are no subpoenas as
Secretary Pompeo observed in his
fittingly tart response on Tuesday what
the committee chairmen issued was merely
a letter its huffing and puffing
notwithstanding the letter is nothing
more than an informal request for
voluntary cooperation legally it has no
compulsion power if anything it is rife
with legal deficiencies and McCarthy is
pointing out here then all of the talk
of impeachment inquiry Democrats haven't
actually utilized the power
or that they have in Congress in order
to subpoena members of the executive
branch why well because then it would
get litigated in the courts because
that's the way this stuff works you
subpoena somebody in the white house the
white house says no and then it ends up
in court and the court hashes it out but
that leads to delay instead what the
Democrats are doing is they are issuing
fake subpoenas basically a request for
people to show up if the White House
says hold up a second they then accuse
the White House of obstruction so this
appears to be manufactured I mentioned
this yesterday but the Democrats are now
using a wide variety of theories in
order to justify their push for
impeachment as it turns out that the
quid pro quo arrangement supposedly
evident from the Trump Ukrainian
president solinsky's phone call falls
apart as it turns out that allegation
doesn't make any sense in the absence of
any information that the Ukrainian
leadership believed that the president
was withholding military aid as that
becomes clear the Democrats are now
shifting the narrative on impeachment
maybe the impeachment is not about quid
pro quo after all maybe it's about
President Trump mouthing off maybe it's
about President Trump yelling at the
whistle blower maybe it's about
obstruction of justice well what if the
Democrats basically box themselves in
here
what if Nancy Pelosi went off
half-cocked because she believed that it
was important to get her base on board
because she couldn't hold them back any
longer because Nancy Pelosi isn't
actually in control of this process
remember earlier this year Nancy Pelosi
tried to take out the squad
earlier this year Nancy Pelosi tried to
marginalize the radicals in her base and
president Trump basically prohibited her
from doing that by attacking the
radicals in her pace forcing her to
rally around them well that meant the
Nancy Pelosi is now subjected to their
whims and that means ironically the
president Trump unifying Nancy Pelosi
with the radicals in her base led to
this faux impeachment inquiry while
sandy mccarthy writes standing
committees do have subpoena power so why
not use it well because subpoenas get
litigated in court when the people or
agencies on the receiving end object
Democrats want to have an impeachment
show inquiry on television they don't
want to defend its bona fide ease in
court and they certainly don't want to
defend their letter threatening
obstruction the Democrats media scribes
note the Chairman's admonition that any
failure by Pompeo to comply shall quote
constitute evidence of obstruction of
the houses impeachment inquiry what a
crock as McCarthy points out in criminal
proceedings prosecutors constantly
demands information and defense
presumptively resist
and then ends up in court he says
congressional Democrats know all of this
many of them are lawyers they're issuing
partisan letters that pose legally
offensive threats rather than subpoenas
because this is a show not impeachment
inquiry subpoenas that don't require
chest beating about obstruction everyone
knows they're compulsory but everyone
also knows they may be held up in court
so what this really looks like overall
is the Democrats basically trying to
drum up something something upon which
they can get Trump in the public mind
and that became eminently clear when it
became clear that the whistleblower in
this particular case was probably
coordinated with Adam shifts office
before the whistleblower complaint was
even elevated to the level of the
Inspector General of the intelligence
community we'll get to that bombshell
story in just a moment first let's talk
about the fact that if you are online
your data is likely exposed unless
you're using a VPN I mean there's just
too many people who are looking for your
data if you're using public Wi-Fi if
you're using unprotected Wi-Fi there's a
good shot that hackers are trying to get
your information if you've ever been
hacked before it is not fun people grab
that credit card information they then
use it against you and buy all sorts of
products and wreck your credit it is
just a pain in the butt even best case
scenario you'll end up having to cancel
all your credit cards and change them
over it really is ridiculous
well not only that it's not just hackers
government's big tech they're all
looking for your data this is why I use
Express VPN it's an app I use to stay
secure online why should you care about
encrypting your data well it's really
easy for people to exploit flaws like a
crack that's KR ack with a k' in case
you want to google it those flaws too
exist
use a VPN and disguise your internet
trafficking it's hard to know whether
your device or network is vulnerable and
if you ever use Wi-Fi at a hotel or
shopping mall you're sending data over
an open network and that means no
encryption you should instead be using
Express VPN and make sure that all of
your data is encrypted all you have to
do is download that Express VPN app on
your smartphone or computer you tap one
button and now voila your data is
protected so if you want the best in
online security and privacy protection
head on over to expressvpn comm slash
been for three extra months free with a
1-year package protect your internet
today with the VPN I trust to keep my
data safe go to express VPN calm slash
pens get started that's expressvpn calm
slash Ben go check them out right now
okay so as I say if this whole thing
feels like it is being drummed up that's
because increasingly the evidence is
that it was kind of drummed up that is
the increasing evidence so let me give
you the breaking
the breaking news here for a yesterday
afternoon Adam Schiff the head of the
House Intelligence Committee the
chairman Democrat who was one of the
leading voices in the Trump Muller saga
he'd go out there on CNN every single
day
he had a pup tents outside the CNN
greenroom and he'd go out there every
single day and declare that just around
the Riverbend like Pocahontas just
around the Riverbend lay the great
revelation that President Trump was in
fact a russian-speaking stooge of
Vladimir Putin makeshift would go on
national TV and he basically suggests
that Donald Trump was Tom what was kevin
costner from no way out and he was
secretly a plant okay well it turns out
all that was nonsense well now Adam Chef
has moved it has moved on to his next
allegation he's like just moving this
thing gradually west he started off in
Russia now he's moved to Ukraine
eventually we'll get to France I mean it
really is absurd now this does not mean
that the whistleblower complaint has no
merit we don't know yet but the fact
that the whistleblower was coordinating
with shifts office to begin with does
raise some suspicions particularly
because the whistleblower complaint was
incredibly well-written I mean just as a
piece of writing in a plus a plus really
good piece of legal writing this led
people to suspect wait a second CIA
officers do not write like that that
sounds like somebody has vetted this
thing this sounds like a lawyer helped
draft this thing well now as it turns
out the Democratic head of the House
Intelligence Committee Adam chef learned
about the outlines of a CIA officers
concerns that President Trump had abused
his power before the officer filed a
whistleblower complaint according to a
spokesman and current and former
American officials as according to the
New York Times the early account by the
future whistleblower shows how
determined he was to make known his
allegations that mr. Trump asked
Ukraine's government to interfere on his
behalf in the 2020 election it also
explains how mr. Schiff knew depressed
for the complaints when the Trump
administration initially blocked
lawmakers from seeing it well I mean it
shows a little more than that I love how
the New York Times is trying to trying
to suggest that the real story here is
that the whistleblower was so determined
to get out his story he went to Adam
show now the real story is that the
whistleblower was coordinating with
shifts office to get the information out
there without going through the proper
channels because here is what happened
according to shifts own aide the CIA
officer approached a House Intelligence
Committee aide with his concerns
and the House Intelligence Committee
said what he was supposed to say said go
get a lawyer and elevated up the chain
he then proceeded to report the entire
story up to Adam chef and Adam Schiff
being a dunce decided to tweet out the
entire story on August 28th on Twitter
now I was suggesting last week that it
was pretty obvious that Schiff had
coordinated with the whistleblower
because he was actually tweeting out the
allegations of the whistleblower
complaint a full two weeks before
Congress was informed of the presence of
the whistleblower complaints which makes
it look a lot more like a coordinated
hit between shifts office and a partisan
whistleblower than it does like a
whistleblower with good information who
is deeply concerned about his country
and simply elevating it up the chain now
two things can be true at once one it
can be a partisan hit two there can be
truth to it but we're still waiting on
the truth to it I'm not I'm not seeing
all of the evidence yet that there was a
quid pro quo I'm not seeing evidence of
criminal activity and neither are the
Democrats which is why the Democrats are
basically thrashing up against the box
of impeachment sort of like that weird
alien creature in the Jake Gyllenhaal
movie life right like what we are
watching right now is the Democrats
searching for another impeachment
strategy given the fact that the
whistleblower complaints and the call do
not match up with a quid pro quo story
and this looks even worse when it
appears again that the entire
whistleblower complaint was coordinated
with shifts office now President Trump
has jumped into the middle of this and
President Trump gave what can only be
described as an epically chaotic press
conference yesterday in front of the
prime minister of Finland who just
looked like he wanted to dig a hole in
the ground because again you basically
become window dressing to the Trump show
you show up and suddenly you're playing
the tree and a Christmas Carol
in any case President Trump went after
Adam Schiff he said Schiff probably
helped the whistleblower write the
complaint Schiff may have learned some
of what the whistleblower knew prior to
the complete it's a scandal that he knew
before I go a step further I think he
probably helped write it okay that's
what the word is and I think it's I give
a lot of respect for the New York Times
for putting it out just happened as I'm
walking up here they handed it to me and
I said to Mike I said whoa that's
something that's big stuff that's a big
story
he knew long before
helped write it too it's a scam okay so
did Schiff actually help write it or did
he merely refer to a lawyer and then he
was playing an inside-outside game now
Trump doesn't actually have to make the
allegation that shift wrote it in order
to do damage to chef if it appears that
Adam Schiff was effectively pushing the
notion that the whistleblower complaint
existed and he knew about it beforehand
and the whistleblower was elevating it
up the chain and then if there was any
hold up Schiff was gonna push from the
outside that's bad enough
Schiff is now responding via The Daily
Beast he had previously denied that his
staff had any contact with the
whistleblower he was on MSNBC just last
week explaining he said we had no
contact with the whistleblower if by we
he means he that may be true if by we he
means the staff that's absolutely a lie
apparently he told The Daily Beast that
his staff had contact with the
whistleblower he said he did not know
definitively at the time if the
complaint had been authored by the same
whistleblower who had approached his
staff but he acknowledged he should have
been more clear now that is him lying oh
I'm sure it was just a second
whistleblower yeah that's that's
probably it that's the ticket
Schiff told the outlet we try not to
confirm when people have come in I was
really thinking along the lines of
wanting him to come in and testify I
regret that I wasn't much more clear oh
that's that's it and then of course
shift went after Trump he said oh well
his behavior at this press conference is
alarming Americans have to be worried
about the stability of our precedent
given the enormous ly erratic and
dangerous swings we have seen him take
in the last few days it is alarming well
now this is just pure gas lighting that
ship is gonna accuse Trump basically of
being a traitor and then if Trump gets
mad about that saying oh you mad bro you
mad bro we should impeach you for being
mad it's like we're gonna impeach you
over the Ukraine stuffing from says well
that's a bunch of crap you know how dare
you get mad obviously you're unstable
we should impeach you for that and then
from psych why doesn't make any sense
well you're confused mr. president
that's why you should be impeached and
Trump went heavy after shift yesterday
and again this will be a fruitful line
of attack because Schiff is indeed
pathologically dishonest about this
stuff I mean again he spends two full
years going on cable television
promising vast revelations about Trump
and Russia that never materialized and
now it turns out that he was lying on
national television when he said that
his staff had no contact with the
whistleblower in this this looks a lot
more and more every day like a Purdue
now again for the 1000th time two things
can be true at once one it could be a
coordinated partisan hit two there could
be legitimacy to it we don't know yet
the evidence is not there yet here's
President Trump going after shift over
shift basically fabricating the contents
of the of the Ukranian transcript shift
did a hearing where he basically made up
a story in his own head about from
threatening the president of Ukraine and
Trump went after him he said like Adam
Schiff is calling me unstable this is a
guy who basically had a mental breakdown
in public Schiff went up and he got as
the chairman of the committee got up and
related a call that didn't take place he
made up the language iPod to believe
nobody's ever seen this I think he had
some kind of a mental breakdown but he
went up to the microphone and he read a
statement from the President of the
United States as if I were on the call
because what happened is when he looked
at the sheet which was an exact
transcript of my call done by very
talented people that do this exact word
for work he said Wow
he didn't do anything wrong so he made
it up
okay so Trump going after chef and he
went after chef even harder yesterday he
suggested he is now pinned a nickname on
Adam Schiff not just little Adam Schiff
or pencil Mac Adam Schiff he's got a new
one for Adam Schiff we'll get to
president Trump's new nickname for Adam
Schiff in just one moment first let's
talk about your sleep quality so are you
sleeping well enough at night asleep is
pretty important you know over the
weekend my kids were both sick and that
meant that I was sleeping with them in
their beds but they don't have a he
would sleep mattress so I didn't do
great in those beds then last night I
climbed into bed in my helix sleep
mattress and let me just tell you that
thing is comfortable as all hell and I
feel refreshed and ready to battle the
day hue exquisite takes just two minutes
to complete it matches your body type
and sleep preferences so the perfect
mattress for you no matter how you sleep
on their side on your back hot sleeper
whatever helix can make exactly what
your body needs just go to helix sleep
calm slash Ben take their two minutes
sleep clothes they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life for a
couple's helix can even split the
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they've got a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will go check them out
right now helix sleep comm slash man
when you use that slash pen you get up
to 120
five bucks off at helix sleep comm slash
pen that is helix sleep comm / Ben from
- 125 bucks off your mattress were again
it's risk-free because they have a 10
year warranty and you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free he would
sleep calm / been a mattress so good I
got one for my sister for her wedding
you really there mattresses are
tremendous check him out he likes sleep
calm / Ben okay so president Trump and
now has a new nickname for Adam Schiff
he's calling him shifty chef which you
could sort of see coming but if the shoe
fits here's President Trump going after
Adam chef and I will just recommend that
if you can actually see this show if
you're a subscriber it's a Lee Weyer and
you're watching this show keep an eye on
the prime minister of Finland who is
just doing a consistent Jim from the
office Finland is a happy country he's a
happy leader too okay if you just get
rid of shifty shift everybody will be
happy the best part of that clip is
where Trump leans over and sort of taps
the Finnish president on the on the knee
and the Finnish president gives him the
the wave off which is pretty spectacular
come on high comedy it is okay and the
reason it's high comedy is because in
the end it's gonna amount to nothing
yeah the Democrats may in fact impeach
Trump over apparently nothing in the
house I really have my doubts that Nancy
Pelosi publicly quote-unquote launches
an impeachment inquiry even if you
didn't change anything legally without
carrying it all the way to fruition it's
just not something that's going to
happen but it's it isn't gonna make a
difference in the election not if
they've got nothing better than this
right they they may have overplayed
their hand pretty dramatically in the
hopes that trump would shoot himself in
the foot by the way Trump yeah he was
talking about the whistle blower the
Democrats have trotted out another line
about Trump and impeachment that Trump
is attacking the whistle blower Trump
said well if the whistle blower is
legitimate of course he should be
protected if he's coordinating outside
the bounds of law then he should not be
protected I think should be protected if
the whistle blowers legitimate but when
the whistle blower makes a big report or
the conversation I had with a president
of Ukraine and it was a great
conversation it was / we talked mostly
about congratulations on your win
we talked about corruption and with
really referring mostly to 2016 because
what the Democrats did in 2016 was
corrupt okay so yeah again I think that
trumps complaints about the whistle
blower given the coordination within the
whistle blower and chef while Trump's
language is never is never modulated
correctly his basic point which is that
the least suspicious about the whistle
blower and the relationship with the
Democrats given that here at times
report hard to argue with them on that
meanwhile a bizarre situation over on
the hill yesterday the State Department
inspector general whose name is linic he
decided to show up on the hill and talk
with Democrats and Republicans the State
Department inspector general was
supposed to deliver a packet of
documents and people on the hill were
suspecting he was going to stop by and
show evidence that the Trump
administration had been pressuring
people inside the State Department to do
his personal political bidding instead
they walked out with a packet of old
news reports about Joe Biden which was
weird
according to James Barrett writing over
at Daily wire immediate urgent meeting
between democratic-led House committees
and the State Department inspector
general on Wednesday turned out to be a
big disappointment for those hoping it
would offer incriminating documents
related to the Democrats impeachment
effort instead of evidence of
retaliation against State Department
officials cooperating with House
Democrats as Reuters and others reported
ahead of the meeting inspector general
Steve linic ended up presenting the
Democrats with months old reports about
Democrats alleged collusion with Ukraine
which Democrats are decrying as
hallucinatory and propagandistic the
information presented at the meeting
Democratic Representative Jamie Raskin
told reporters on Wednesday feels like a
completely irrelevant distraction from
the work at hand so Democrats were
expecting some sort of damning material
on Trump and as it turns out what ended
up coming back was a bunch of old media
reports about Democrats working with
Ukraine to affect the 2016 election very
unfortunate for Democrats we had some
more of that in just one second okay so
yesterday I got to tell you yesterday
was not a great day for me physically
why was yesterday not a great day for me
physically well because it was a fast it
was a Jewish fast day and that meant no
drinking and no eating and three hours
of radio and the podcast that is a lot I
sure could have used a liquid IV
infusion at that point
Koecher but I promise you that Michel
moles the execrable and Andrew Klavan
who only stays alive basically thanks to
liquid IV they were badgering me
yesterday that I should have just hooked
up that liquid so what exactly is liquid
IV well it's the fastest most efficient
way to stay hydrated it hydrates you
faster and more efficiently than water
alone with an added bonus of vitamins C
b3 b5 b6 and b12 it is the fastest
growing wellness brand in America you
can find them everywhere even at Costco
all liquid IV products utilize cellular
transport technology a specific ratio of
glucose sodium mine salt and potassium
when mixed with 16 ounces of water it
helps your body absorb more of the water
and nutrients you drink directly into
your bloodstream and that convenience he
has a friendly powder package for travel
by the way which does help prevent
jetlag and altitude sickness you need to
stay hydrated I found that out yesterday
don't find it out the hard way and said
go check out liquid IV you will love it
right now my listeners get 25% off and
liquid IV calm when you use my code been
a checkout that is 25% off anything you
order on liquid IVs website go to liquid
IV comm enter my promo code Ben to get
your savings start getting better
hydration that is liquid IV calm promo
code Ben don't wait start properly
hydrating today okay so what exactly
happened in this meeting well according
to CBS in a briefing on Capitol Hill the
State Department Inspector General gave
attendees a packet of hallucinatory
propagandistic materials and articles
about Ukraine Biden Giuliani Trump
hotels and other matters that were sent
to the Secretary of State several months
ago according to Democratic
Representative Jamie Raskin and
congressional aides the cover sheet of
the documents which was written in
calligraphy claims to have been sent
from the White House CBS reports but
nobody really knows who sent the
materials and later turned out that Rudy
Giuliani said it was me
so I mean come on like this is worthy of
informing Congress about that Rudy
Giuliani sends weird zodiac letter love
notes to the State Department by the way
what that does tend to show is that the
Trump administration was not going to
the State Department and saying top down
we want you to go investigate all this
stuff yeah Rudy Giuliani from the
outside as part of the Trump campaign
sending a letter to the State Department
and saying you know what you should
investigate all this stuff now if the
State Department initiated an
investigation on that grounds is that
cause for great concern here is Rudy
Giuliani
talking so rude anyway Rudy Guiliani
know when he talks about all this he's
always weird about it he acknowledged
that he had sent this entire package to
the State Department and his idea was
that he was going to inform them of
stuff that they should check out
CNN reported and that it was indeed
Giuliani who turned over the documents
he told CNN Wednesday evening that some
of the documents provided to Congress by
the State Department's IG had originated
with him he apparently gave the
documents to the White House which then
passed them to Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo according to a source familiar
with the matter
Pompeyo then gave the documents to a
subordinate who provided them to the
legal counsel at the State Department
and the documents were ultimately given
to the inspector general Giuliani said
that in late March he had routed what he
called an outline of allegations against
Biden as well as Murray Ivanovich who is
the ambassador to Ukraine from the
United States to Pompey's office he said
he had also sent details of his
interviews from earlier in the year with
the incumbent and former top prosecutors
in Ukraine who helped provide him with
the information in his outline Giuliani
said he received a phone call shortly
thereafter from Pompey oh who told you
Leon E he'd be referring the documents
for investigation Giuliani told CNN they
told me they were going to investigate
it now again that is not corruption per
se I mean it depends on whether in fact
they were doing this for campaign
purposes or whether they were actually
investigating corruption in Ukraine and
it looks very much like frankly the
attempt by the Hillary Clinton campaign
to route information from fusion GPS to
the Obama era FBI right in other words
funneling information into an
administration which is then checked out
does not amount to an actual violation
of law it may be politically partisan
but that does not amount to an actual
violation of law so this is all a little
bit strange again that's not a it's not
a violation of one it's just Rudy
Giuliani being a weirdo and then his
information being passed around and the
Democrats were very disappointed
yesterday in other words they were
looking forward to some sort of
testimony about how Trump was pressuring
people internally to do his bidding and
that is not exactly what happened
nonetheless the Democrats are trying to
play this up suggesting that there are
troubling questions about apparent
efforts inside and outside the Trump
administration to target specific
officials including Joe Biden's son
Annmarie ivanovitch there is this weird
thing that is breaking out in the in the
media today specifically with regards to
the control of the executive branch like
there's a whole article in The New York
Times about how the executive branch and
career officers in the State Department
well they feel under threat by the Trump
administration well last I checked the
Trump administration is in charge of its
own State Department so as long as that
is the case there's not really a legal
problem there now again you can say all
of this is inappropriate you can say
that that the State Department should
not become the go-between for Rudy
Giuliani and the Trump administration
you can say that that this is misuse of
public resources but then you're gonna
get into the dicey question of how often
public resources are misused for
campaign leveraged issues again a
heavily Clinton's campaign was obviously
leveraging information to Obama's FBI
with regard to for example the steel
dossier so that is not what about ISM
that is what is the standard for
impeachable offenses or crime and so far
not a lot of evidence of crime a lot of
evidence of ugly swampy politics but not
a lot of evidence of crime it meanwhile
the the media are trying to drag mike
pence into this so there's a report from
The Washington Post today that President
Trump repeatedly involved vice president
pence in efforts to exert pressure on
the leader of Ukraine at a time when the
president was using other channels to
solicit information he hoped would be
damaging to a democratic rival according
to current and former US officials but
pence wasn't aware of any of this so the
attempt to rope pence into this scandal
is not exactly going to meet with tons
of success Trump instructed pence not to
attend the inauguration of ukrainian
president vladimir zalenski in May an
event White House officials had pushed
to put on the VP's calendar when
Ukraine's new leader was seeking
recognition and support from Washington
months later the president used pence to
tell zalenski the US aid was still being
withheld while demanding more aggressive
action on corruption officials said now
again we know that the vice president of
the United States in the last
administration was pressuring the
Ukrainians with 1 billion dollars in
American loan guarantees to get rid of
corruption withholding the VP's
attendance at a particular at a
particular event to push against
corruption doesn't seem like anything
supremely out-of-the-box at the time
following from July 25th phone
Solinsky the Ukrainians probably
understood action on corruption to
include the investigation of former Vice
President Joe Biden and his son hunter
Biden according to the Washington Post
but that is speculation right so it is
possible that if they'd not investigated
Joe and hunter Biden but they
investigated other corruption that Pence
goes to the thing so now they're trying
to downgrade the quid pro quo from four
hundred million dollars in military aid
to vice president pence didn't go to an
event for zalenski that's a lot weaker
officials close depends insist he was
unaware of Trump's efforts to press
Lewinsky for damaging information about
Biden and his son who had served on the
board of an muscaria crane Ian gas
company when his father was overseeing
US policy on Ukraine Pence's activities
occurred amid several indications of the
president's hidden agenda among them
were the abrupt removal of the US
ambassador to Kiev the visible efforts
by the president's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
to insert himself in the u.s. Ukraine
relationship as well as alarms being
raised inside the White House even
before the emergence of an extraordinary
whistleblower complaints about president
Trump's conduct according to the
Washington Post perhaps most
significantly one of Pence's top
advisors was on the July 25th call and
the VP should have had access to the
transcript within hours right but why
exactly would pence like spend lots of
time perusing a transcript to the
president of Ukraine
I had my doubts that that is what
vice-president pence does with his day
so now they're trying to rope pence into
this why because the suggestion is if
they can impeach Trump and they can also
impeach pence and if they can impeach
pence and guess who becomes presidents
of the United States Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi yeah good luck with
that
good luck with that now again all of
this also rests on a basic assumption
which is that it is illegitimate to
investigate Joe Biden hunter Biden then
nothing untoward happened with regard to
Joe Biden and hunter Biden right Joe
Biden is trying to make that case today
he says no one has ever asserted I did
anything wrong on Ukraine well no
actually there are a fair number of
people who have their suspicions that
you did something wrong on Ukraine
including the other Democratic
presidential candidates who continued to
maintain that they will not answer
questions about whether they would have
allowed their VP's kids to do business
in countries where the VP was presiding
over foreign policy here is Biden trying
to shy away from all of this I think we
should just focus on he's the issue
nobody has ever asserted the
I did anything wrong except tea and
what's that fellas name Rudy Hootie okay
so so that there is Biden trying to deny
all of this president Trump for his part
is going hearted Biden basically saying
listen there is nothing wrong with me
asking about Joe Biden and hunter Biden
in the generalized context of corruption
in Ukraine particularly as has to do
with the 2016 election because Rudy
Giuliani is making the claim that the
2016 election was actually impacted by
Ukrainian not Russian influence I mean
that there is a story out today
specifically about a Ukrainian
prosecutor Viktor Shokan the one who is
now at the center of the Joe Biden
allegations he's the one that Joe Biden
wanted fired Shokan apparently has told
a variety of people including John
Solomon that of the hill that the that
he was basically pressured to drop the
Joe the Joe Biden case while he was
prosecutor so if that's the case then
all of this is back on right Fox News
reported this yesterday according to Fox
News the fired prosecutor at the center
of the Ukraine controversy said during a
private interview with the president's
personal attorney Rudy Giuliani earlier
this year that he was told to back off
an investigation involving Purisima that
is the company that was linked to Joe
Biden's son
according to details of that interview
that were handed over to Congress by the
State Department's inspector general on
Wednesday so Giuliani was basically
taking notes he sent them to the State
Department why don't you and if you're
talking about in corruption you should
probably investigate this whole Joe
Biden Viktor shokhin thing right that
was some of the documents that were
turned over by the State Department
Inspector General in all of this it will
get to more of this in just one second
is the Biden issue still a live issue if
so that also casts a different light on
Trump mentioning Biden in that call with
zalenski
again there's no quid pro quo in that
call given that the Ukrainians didn't
know military aid was even being
withheld we got some more of that in
just one second first let's talk about
your sleep quality but with regard
specifically to your CPAP so if you have
sleep apnea a huge percentage of
Americans have sleep apnea my dad has
sleep apnea and he has a CPAP machine
and basically it's kept him alive and
the CPAP machine is a wonderful
invention however it is incredibly
annoying to clean it's very difficult to
clean there nearly 1 billion into
Jools affected by sleep apnea around the
world there are lots of negative health
issues that can arise when CPAP
equipment is not cleaned properly so if
you want a safe and effective automated
sanitizing solution you should check out
so clean it is the world's first
automated CPAP cleaner and sanitizer so
clean kills up to 99.9% of all CPAP
terms in bacteria that can build up in
your mask hose and reservoir it's easy
to use you just put the mask in you
close the lid you walk away and works
with all the popular CPAP machines and
masks so clean it uses advanced
technology to sanitize your CPAP
equipment with just the touch of a
button it is a safer healthier way to
breathe cleaner and have a better CPAP
experience if you want to have a better
night's rest if you wanna make sure that
you're not breathing in all sorts of
stuff you shouldn't you really should
check out so clean right now for our
listeners
you can try so clean risk-free for 30
nights even shipping is free so don't
wait go to so clean calm right now take
advantage of the 30 night risk free
trial and free shipping that is so clean
calm again so clean calm okay we'll get
to more of Joe Biden and is there a
there there may be may be certainly the
Democrats do not want to talk about
whether there is a there there we'll get
to that in just one second first good
news for another Kingdom fans the third
and final season is here this month
October 7th episodes 1 & 2 will be
released if you are a subscriber over a
daily wire you can exclusive access to
both tomorrow so don't wait subscribe
right now also seasons 1 & 2 available
at Taylor wired icon make sure to check
those out and get caught up it's really
a lot of fun also if you're a subscriber
you know you get special access to our
Sunday special including material behind
the paywall you get our Sunday special
on Saturday this week we sat down with
my friend Megan McCain and it really is
a it is a spectacular episode here's a
little bit of what it sounds like
there just really isn't a lot of
compromise so I just thought if I'm
gonna do this job this way I just have
to 100% not care what anybody thinks but
really not care what the left thinks but
what I have in return is so much better
because I think that I feel gratitude
and the fact that I can represent so
many people who are voiceless in the
mainstream media that's talked up my own
interviews but this is a fantastic
interview Megan McCain is a great guest
and we go over everything from her dad
and his legacy to what it's like to be
the only conservative really on the view
every day it's it's just speak to get
into some really kind of deep personal
issues it's really fantastic go check it
out this Sunday you can get an early on
Saturday if your subscriber also when
you get the annual subscription of
course you get this the very greatest
and beverage vessels yesterday let me
tell you I was itching to drink from the
very greatest and beverage vessels my
throat was just killing me and I was
looking for the refreshing refreshing
beverage that came in this beverage
vessel unfortunately it was a Jewish
fast day it's that time of year is home
Gedaliah yesterday which is another one
of the fast about the destruction of the
Jerusalem we have another fast day next
week when I won't be able to use the
leftist ears hot or cold tell me but
that is why I'm drinking copiously from
it today to replenish my bottle my
precious bodily fluids go check that out
yet for 99 bucks a year you get the very
greatest in beverage vessels please
subscribe we really appreciate it we're
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so what is fascinating about the whole
Ukraine Joe Biden thing is how hard the
media are working to pretend that
nothing untoward happened not only with
Joe Biden but also with the 2016
campaign it was political that first
reported in 2017 that the Hillary
Clinton campaign and the DNC had been
openly coordinating with the Ukrainian
embassy to dig up information on palm
Anna for that they could use against the
Trump campaign and that the Obama
administration was involved as well in
that effort right all of that has been
reported over the past couple of years
now we're supposed to pretend that all
of the Ukrainian influence in the
election was basically on the up and up
so we were supposed to let's just be
straight we were supposed to focus on
Russian interference in the election up
through 2019 until the Mullah report
ended and then as soon as the Mullen
report ended we are no longer supposed
to focus on Ukrainian influence and now
we're supposed to focus on Trump trying
to influence Ukraine so we shift our
focus to Ukraine but again the theory of
the media and the Democrats seems to be
that Trump is this god-like figure where
he speaks things into existence so Trump
says Russia and suddenly the story is
Russia for three years then Trump says
Ukraine and the story is Trump and
Ukraine but at no point are we allowed
to look at Ukraine not with regard to
Trump using Ukraine both with regards to
trumping targeted by forces within
Ukraine and the opposite is true also
we're not supposed to look at Russia
when Barack Obama was president were
only supposed to do it when Donald Trump
talks about Russia and so all the world
revolves around getting Donald Trump
right you may notice there's a pattern
to all of this like listen to this
report from the Washington Post quote in
his quest to rewrite the history of the
2016 election President Trump's personal
attorney has turned to an unusual source
of information
Trump's imprisoned former campaign
Chairman Paul mana for rewrite the
history of the 2016 election well I mean
again Politico did report that the
Hillary Clinton campaign was digging up
dirt with Ukrainian embassy on Trump's
campaign manager now as Politico it's
not Giuliani apparently Giuliani
consulted with Paul Manafort which makes
him sense because Paul Manafort was
deeply embedded in the politics of
Ukraine and of course was apparently
deeply corrupt the relationship with
Julian which Giuliani acknowledged in an
interview this week with the Washington
Post stems from a shared interest in a
narrative that undermines the rationale
for the Special Counsel investigation
that inquiry led to manna forts
imprisonment on tax
financial fraud allegations related to
his work in Kiev from the political
party of former President Viktor
Yanukovych apparently a bunch of
different Republicans have jumped into
the fray this is not just a Giuliani
thing anymore Senator Chuck Schumer
who's chairman of the Senate Finance
Committee and Senator Ron Johnson
chairman of the Homeland Security
Committee have announced their renewal
of an inquiry into any coordination
between Ukraine and democratic party
officials which again it makes some
sense a president Trump has been mocking
Joe Biden on this they're basically two
stories with regards Ukraine and we
shouldn't conflate them one is Joe Biden
attempting to influence the interior
politics of Ukraine by withholding loans
and at the same time the prosecutor he
was targeting who he may or may not have
been targeting for good reasons ramming
the EU the IMF the World Bank they all
didn't like this prosecutor but that
prosecutor was apparently presiding over
an investigation into Biden son like
that Story number one and then Story
number two is Hillary Clinton and the
TNC and the Obama administration
coordinating with the Ukrainian embassy
to dig up dirt on Trump's team during
the 2016 election right those are two
separate stories president Trump has
been going hard after Biden yesterday he
tweeted what is one of the funniest
weeks of his presidency he tweeted out
look at the picture and used a
Nickelback a Nickelback video to do so
Twitter has now pulled it down for
copyright infringement which is just
ridiculous it's obviously satire it's a
clip of Joe Biden explaining that he's
never spoken to his own son about
overseas business dealings juxtaposed
with a picture of hunter Biden Joe Biden
and Ukrainian gas official all golfing
together have you ever spoken to your
son about his overseas business dealings
I've never spoken to my son about his
overseas
[Music]
okay that's pretty spectacular that is
some grade a presidential tweets
trolling Trump was it didn't bother what
the Nickelback references yesterday and
oppressor he just said Biden and his son
are stone-cold crooked now let's be real
about this hunter Biden probably is
stone-cold crooked okay I don't know
about Joe and there are lots at when
when you are a famous person there are
lots of hangers-on who probably tried to
use your name to get access in high
places
the fact is that hunter Biden who is
basically a failure and everything he
has ever tried was getting paid fifty
thousand dollars a month to be on the
board of the Ukrainian gas company you
can't imagine it's because of his
expertise in oil and natural gas
probably do with the fact his dad he was
VP of the United States is that on Joe
Biden I mean not really lots of people
are sympathetic toward their own kids
President Trump is sympathetic toward
his own kids would that said does that
exonerate Joe Biden not really here's
Trump going after them and his son our
stone called crooked and you know it his
son walks out with millions of dollars
the kid knows nothing you know it and so
do we go ahead ask the question sir was
what did you want president to Lenski to
do about president Vice President Biden
and his son hunter you talking to me I'm
walking here you talking any case the
Democrats are trying to downplay all of
this obviously so John Brennan who is
the head of the the CIA while he was in
the Obama administration and who
proceeded to spend two years again
claiming that there would be undisclosed
information linking president Trump to
Vladimir Putin demonstrating that he was
in fact a traitor now he's like I don't
want to look at the 2016 election
anymore why are we even looking at the
2016 election so just to get this
straight
for two long years all the Democrats
wanted to talk about was corruption in
the 2016 election now and Trump raises
the question about whether there is
Ukrainian interference in the 2016
election again based on published
reports in places like Politico John
Brennan's like I'm we probably shouldn't
lead we look into that now
and nothing to see here nothing to see
here pay no attention to the John
Brennan behind the curtain
William bar you know when he was testify
in front of Congress he said he he
didn't understand the predication of the
counterintelligence investigation that
was launched into Russia's interference
in 2016 election I don't understand the
predication
of this worldwide effort to try to
uncover dirt either real or imagined
that would discredit that investigation
in 2016 and into Russian interference
you know one hand the abomination is
crucified for not doing enough and now
they're looking for what we might have
done in order to try to understand
better and to prevent the Russian
interference well no I mean John Brennan
contradicts himself seven ways from
Sunday in this clip alone right he says
you know I'm William Barwon out there
and he said why are we investigating
Russia well why are we investigating
Ukraine okay well you wanted Russia
investigated so actually the hypocrisy
here is you you wanted to interfere it
certain for an investigation you want to
investigate certain foreign interference
into the election but not other foreign
interference in the election he says
well we were criticized for not doing
enough and now they're saying that we
did too much well no they're wondering
if you launched an investigation under
false auspices then that would make a
difference if you're talking about the
use of public dollars for electioneering
it seems to me that if it turns out that
the Trump Russia investigation was
launched on false premises in order to
get Trump that makes a difference and if
it turns out that the Obama
administration or the Hillary campaign
were coordinating with the Ukrainians
that seems like that would be impactful
as well especially if you want to
prevent future interference in elections
John Solomon who's been reporting on
this incessantly from the hill again
people keep saying that John Solomon is
reporting on this has been debunked I've
seen no evidence that his reporting on
this has been debunked he says that a
Ukrainian Court has already found that
leaked documents affected the 2016
election from Ukraine about the evidence
Ukraine meddled in our election they say
no no that didn't happen did that happen
yeah it did a Ukrainian Court has ruled
in December of last year that a senior
law enforcement official and a
parliamentary member intentionally
leaked documents about Paul Manafort and
Donald Trump in an effort to intervene
in the u.s. election
that is an official ruling of a
Ukrainian Court okay so that much is
true some again all of this is a mess
basically you've got the White House
investigating Ukraine and the State
Department investigating Ukraine and
then you've got the the Congress
investigating the White House for
investigating Ukraine it's all a mess is
any of it impeachable does any of this
have to do with impeachment it seems
like we're pretty far afield right
that's funny I was talking to my mom who
kind of follows this stuff I would say
peripherally and she follows it closely
enough that she sort of knows what's
going on but she's not in the weeds on
this and maybe over the weekend she was
asking me so what's the deal with
dissing Pietschmann stuff and I started
to try and explain it to her I got about
a paragraph in and she said sounds like
bullcrap
and I feel like that's how most
Americans are gonna respond because this
started off with a very clear allegation
the Trump was engaged in a quid pro quo
with the Ukrainian government right the
Trump was basically paying off the
Ukrainian government to investigate his
domestic political opponents and now
we've got did Ukraine interfere in the
2016 election what was really Giuliani
doing in Ukraine did the Democrats
coordinate with the whistleblower is
there any criminal activity if there is
no quid pro quo maybe there's a second
or a quid pro quo with Mike Pence but
pence didn't know about like it's all
very very complicated and more
complicated this gets the harder a sell
it is to the American public now it's
funny I got a question you know to let
you behind the stages of what happens
here the day they were I got a question
from a member of the media the other day
about the impeachment effort it was from
somebody on the Left obviously and this
person said well you know I would I
don't understand is Republicans who are
sticking by Trump now why don't they
just say well you know so fine we got
president Pence like what would be the
big deal okay a couple of things one
people should not be impeached over a
non-criminal behavior seems like a
pretty obvious one like the truth
actually matters and two the fact is
that Republicans rightly see this I
think based on the current evidence as a
smear against against Republicans
generally and this reporter was asking
me you know I get the theory that
Republicans sort of see Trump as their
avatar and so an attack on Trump is an
attack on them and I said well no you're
getting this wrong you've got the
polarity reversed Republican voters feel
like they've been attacked by the media
we feel like we have been attacked by
the powers that be we feel like the
Democratic Party has been targeting us
as bitter clingers who cling to our God
and our guns
we feel like we've been targeted for
years and then Trump gets elected and
you throw exactly the same accusations
but you put on top of it a bunch of
politically motivated accusations that
he's a traitor and so it's not that
Trump is somehow like the tip of the
spear
it's that Trump is in fact the attacks
on Trump are so similar to the attacks
on conservatives generally that
conservative C attacks on Trump and they
say well that is an attack on me because
if Trump weren't here they'd still be
attacking me the same way and they're
right about this
the reason that Trump is popular in
Republican circles is because the left
is consistently attacking him and
because Trump is aggressive
Trump's aggressive instinct his
willingness to fight back is indeed what
endear him to the Republican base that's
why he's the president right now so for
all the talk that you know listen I'll
talk about how I think he's not focused
enough in his push back
I think he's scattershot now I think
that he's wild on Twitter the fact is
that his aggressive instinct is the
reason that he was popular among
Republicans and here's perfect Devin
some president from yesterday he was
talking about Nancy Pelosi and the
Democrats getting very aggressive and he
says listen Paul Ryan never did this now
look at Nancy Pelosi Nancy Pelosi hands
out subpoenas like you know she has to
approve it she hands out subpoenas like
their cookies you want a subpoena here
you go take them like their cookies Paul
Ryan would never give anybody a subpoena
no let's talk about it that's a big
thing to give a subpoena let's talk
about it two weeks later they're still
talking they wanted subpoenas to
investigate the corrupt Democrats and
the corrupt people on the other side
Paul Ryan would not give subpoenas okay
so his idea here is that Republicans
have always played by the rules and
Democrats never play by the rules so I'm
not gonna play by the rules that does
into your Trump because the fact is that
Democrats don't play by the rules and
every story that comes out about Adam
Schiff coordinating with whistleblowers
makes this seem less like an honest
attempt to get to the bottom of a
violation of law and much more like an
attempt to get president from meanwhile
the Democrats it is amazing yeah just as
proof of the the sort of hypocrisy here
you know Hillary Clinton continues to
maintain that she won the 2016 election
and she came out yesterday and said that
President Trump is an illegitimate
president that was her line she also
suggested that she lost in 2016 because
she was too serious not because she was
a garbage candidate here she was on the
view I'm a theory
person but I'm also a fun person but I
think I probably came across as too
serious and too you know I really
believed that my job especially as a
woman and though and the first woman to
go as far as I did that I had to help
people feel good about a woman in the
Oval Office a woman commander in chief
and so I may have over corrected a
little bit because sometimes people say
oh why can't you be like that or why
weren't you like that okay so again
Hillary Clinton trying to claim that she
lost because she wasn't fun enough yeah
lady when you look up on not fun the
opposite of fun in the antonym
dictionary my goodness Hillary Clinton
definitely comes up on that list pretty
astonishing by the way the Democrats
continue to push forward this
impeachment stuff largely because they
are having trouble seeing how any of
their candidates are a walk away to
defeat Trump Kamala Harris who again has
become Glenn Close in fatal attraction
boiling rabbits for attention she says
that we should bring Mike Pence before
Congress now that's how far afield we've
gone over Oh Chris Matthews everybody
stay up in the morning coming at the
show coming your question come out of
here she lasts all weird then I got
rollaway on this chair ah I drink a
little and come back in the next morning
go Kamala Harris go you're raising a
very important point which is that the
vice president has a lot to answer to
and he also should be brought before the
United States Congress to speak about
what exactly was his involvement and
what if any solicitations were made by
the president to have the vice president
engage in in in the unethical conduct
yeah and this is just it's getting too
far afield at this point too far afield
and Trump is fighting back with
everything including the kitchen sink
and breaking news according to the
Associated Press president from said two
remarks to in remarks to reporters
outside the White House quote China
should start an investigation into the
Biden's so now it's not just Ukraine
yeah here's thing that Trump he's not
hiding the ball okay for all the talk
about Trump you know secretly behind the
scenes manipulating things this is a
dude who does not hide the ball hey ever
ever I mean he just everything is right
out there he's not hiding anything and
this is a guy who I mean
the way that he met Melania Trump is he
was
event or shoes with another dude and he
just walked up to her and gave her his
phone number I mean that is what Trump
is in a nutshell right Trump is not a
manipulative player from behind the
scenes he doesn't have a plan he just
says it I mean so he said it about China
today
so the Democrats will undoubtedly claim
that this is now impeachable - right
even though it's just Trump mouthing off
since China should start an
investigation into the Biden's he said
he had not directly asked Chinese
President Xi Jinping to investigate
Biden and his son hunter but he said
it's certainly something we could start
thinking about Trump and personal where
Rudy Guiliani have tried to raise
suspicions about hunter Biden's business
dealings in China leaning on the
writings of conservative author Peter
Schweitzer by the way if there's one
author who's made a huge difference in
the course of American elections it
would be Schweitzer was very
instrumental in Hillary and email gate
and all the rest of it even and the
corruption inside the Hillary Clinton
State Department and the Clinton
Foundation Trump is not hiding the ball
here so basically this has turned back
into the miasma of fighting none of it
sounds impeachable all of it is
confusing and chaotic and that is why
this effort in the end is gonna go
nowhere I think okay time for a quick
thing I like and then some things that I
hate so things that I like today so this
was just an unbelievable thing so Botham
gene is this accountant black accountant
who was horrific Lee and tragically
killed murdered by a police officer
off-duty named amber Geiger she walked
into an apartment she thought was her
she saw a bathroom gene in there and she
shot him to death well yesterday she was
sentenced to 10 years in prison which
seems like an appropriate sentence for
what probably was manslaughter but was
convicted his first-degree murder Brandt
gene was bath and jeans brother and I
mean you want to talk about a person
with absolute class you want to talk
about a person with just integrity and
decency this is an amazing amazing thing
here he is at the sentencing hearing
asking if he can give the woman who
killed his brother a hug I mean it's
just it's an unbelievable thing I mean I
I wish you know I hope that God forbid
in a similar circumstance I would have
this kind of normal quality is an
incredible incredible thing here's brand
Jeanne I forgive you I know if you go to
God and ask him
he will forgive you I don't even want
you to go to jail I want the best for
you because I know that's what that's
exactly what both one would want you to
do and the best would be give your life
to Christ I don't know if this is
possible but okay
can I give her please I mean that's just
men well what a human being equality
what a human being of quality okay time
for a quick thing that I hate okay so
the federal government apparently has
dramatically expanded its exposure to
risky mortgages it's as though we don't
learn anything ever in this country so
according to the Washington Post the
federal government has dramatically
expanded its exposure to risky mortgages
as federal officials over the past four
years took steps that cleared the way
for companies to issue loans that many
borrowers may not be able to repay
because it turns out that we have in
this country a very conflicting set of
principles principle number one you
should pay back what you owe principle
number two if you can't buy a house
that's our fault and we should pick up
the risk Fannie Mae Freddie Mac the
Federal Housing Administration are now
guaranteeing almost 7 trillion dollars
in mortgage related debt the federal
government should have nothing to do
with guaranteeing mortgages nothing it
should be completely on banks to
guarantee mortgages why I should be on
the hook for you not paying your
mortgage is ridiculous and vice versa if
I can't pay my mortgage that is a me
problem and if you can't pay your
mortgage that is a you problem and the
fact that people don't seem to
understand this and they want the
federal government to boost
homeownership by guaranteeing loans is
insane it's insane it's how we ended up
in the subprime crisis in the first
place in 2007-2008 apparently that seven
trillion dollars in mortgage related
debt is 33% more than before the housing
crisis so the housing crisis was in
large part caused by a belief by the
federal government that sponsoring
subprime mortgages that we're going to
default would turn out fine because real
estate values would continue to rise so
Lending's
lending companies banks they be able to
foreclose on the property and still not
lose money which means that the federal
government would never have to backstop
this stuff then the real estate market
crashes people are getting foreclosed
upon and guess who has to step in their
solution to that is let's get more in
the federal lending business these
entities Fannie Mae Freddie Mac the FHA
our run or backstop by the US government
so a large increase in loan defaults
could cost taxpayers hundreds of
billions of dollars the risk is a direct
result of pressure from the lending
industry consumer groups and political
appointees who clamored for the
government to intervene when home
ownership rates fell several years ago
starting in the Obama administration
numerous government officials obliged
mistakenly expecting that the private
market ultimately would take over why
would it take over why exactly would the
private market take over for loans that
they were never going to be able to
support in the first place in 2019
according to data from the Urban
Institute there is now more government
backed housing debt that in any other
point in American history
taxpayers are shouldering much of the
risk a growing number of homeowners face
debt payments that amount to nearly half
of their monthly income a threshold many
experts consider is considered too steep
the basic rule used to be don't spend
more than 20% on your mortgage of what
are you making monthly income now it's
like 33% spending 50% means you have a
high likelihood of defaulting roughly 30
percent of the loans Fannie Mae
guarantee last year exceeded that level
up from 14 percent in 2016 ok that's
insane and again that is driven by the
idea that government is the solution to
all ills it is not it makes things worse
it makes things worse and it's only
gonna become clear when the real estate
market tanks already we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Jess WA alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew Klavan host of
the Andrew Klavan show it seems
president Trump is getting sick and
tired of being lied about 24 hours a day
seven days a week the press can't
understand it what's the big deal they
say isn't that what we always do two
Republican presidents hilarity ensues on
the Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew clay